Yeah.
Piaget,
the developmental psychologist who's a very smart guy,
he pointed out something very interesting.
He said,
now imagine you ran a set of iterated games as a competition and in one iterated
game the rule was you bloody well do what I tell you to.
And the other one is,
well,
we'll all get together and decide how we're going to do this.
Okay,
now we run the competition.
Uh,
Piaget's claim is you do what I tell you fail.
And the reason for that is I have to impose force in order to keep you
cooperating.
And the imposition of forest is a cost.
It's an efficiency cost.
And across time that efficiency cost is going to multiply.
And the equilibrated state solution,
which is the one where we all agree it wins.
Now that's worth thinking about.
You think you think about that locally.
So you've got,
you're trying to organize your family,
you have a little family conference about who's doing what in the household and
what do you,
if you want peace and harmony and an iterated game,
you get everybody to say,
well,
here's the tasks and we they have to be done.
People have to agree on that.
And then you say,
well,
which task would you do?
You have to some how about you?
And you know,
which task would you do?
And everybody agrees.
And then you say,
well,
unless you can come up with a better solution,
that's the one we're going to go with.
And then people can be a little resentful and angry about the conditions of
existence where they have to work,
but they can't really blame that on anyone else.
And maybe that's the best solution you could come up with.
And that was Piaget's idea of the [inaudible] state.
It was like,
it's a voluntary agreement that can be iterated across time that works at
multiple levels of social organization.
Man,
that's a serious,
serious,
serious set of constraints.
And Piaget.
By the way,
it was looking for a way to reconcile science and religion.
He was looking for a biological origin to morality and he thought he found it in
the idea of the equilla braided state and it's even deeper than that.
So imagine this equilibrating state ideas.
Actually there's something to it that if you set the the state up property,
it will iterate across time so long that it becomes a permanent part of the
environment.
The hierarchy is exactly,
that's exactly what a hierarchies.
Hierarchies are 350 million years old.
They're not that patriarchal invention of white European Christian males in the
last 300 years.
There are 350 million years old.
They're stable,
they're stable solutions to this iterative game problem and they've been around
so long that we're actually adapted to the,
and that's part of the reason we have archetypal representations of the social
structure.
So and then we also have architectural representations of the relationship of
the individual to the social structure.
Your job as an individual in relationship to the social structure is to embody
the social structure,
but also just serve as as its eyes and its mouth.
So that can update itself would necessary.
So you take on the mantle of your father,
let's say,
but he's dead.
He's the path he can't see.
You can see.
So you take the structure that's already there and you modify it where it's
necessary and that modification process is necessary or the state becomes too
static and collapses.
And that's why the state has to be subordinate to the individual.
And that's what Western culture has discovered and we can't just let them go.
That's the idea.
The logos,
that's a big idea.
And you'd want to live somewhere where you want to live somewhere where the
individual is subordinate to the state.
It's like,
hey,
go right ahead.
There's lots of places like that,
man,
emigrate go there.
90% of the world's countries are like that.
If you want to live like that,
man,
go find out what it's like.
You don't see immigration going there,
that's for sure.
Okay,
so that's a big mistake that the postmodernist made.
It's not trivial.
That's a big mistake,
but it's not the only one.